we have a voicemail number it's 2192
david p here's an interesting little
question in the voicemail this week uh
hi David uh my question is would you
consider naming a show the david pakman
show narcissistic and have you ever
thought up of uh thought of rather yeah
uh using one of those texts now profiles
to receive text questions from your
audience who okay i'll do the second
question first you can text our
voicemail number 219 to david p not only
can you call me voicemail you can text
it as well there's actually a very
strange string of wrong texts going on
with the voicemail number but that's
maybe a story for the bonus show as far
as is it narcissistic to call the david
pakman show the david pakman show
absolutely it's narcissistic now i don't
know i mean the show used to be called
mid-week politics with david pakman
because it used to be on wednesdays then
it wasn't and i tried to think of
different names a lot of them were
related to time of day like tonight or
today or whatever then I realized
different stations air the show at
different times of day so it might end
up just being very confusing so the
david pakman show was more selected out
of simplicity than anything else yeah
there are plenty of shows on cable
networks and more independent shows that
they use the same kind of approach like
the Rachel Maddow Show yeah although
maybe they're all narcissism possibility
on the bonus show today an update on
coffee label vote voting coffee label
voting that's kind of hard to go from
the beat about me label voting maybe
it's cuz uh English is my second
language I don't know forty-seven
percent of jobs will disappear in the
next 25 years so says Oxford University
and an Illinois man has been sentenced
to 22 years in prison for stealing a TV
remote we will dig into those stories
and more david pakman.com slash
membership and of course coupon code i
voted 17 for a discount and of course of
course david pakman.com slash donate the
indiegogo campaign continues